get ready for a tragic comic Clash of
the symbiotes venom star Tom Hardy
recently took to Instagram to post cool
fan art based on the classic tragedy and
comedy mass that date back to Greek
theater these have a lot more tongue
though part knee clearly relishes
playing the iconic Marvel antihero and
the artwork makes reference to Venom's
post-credit scene which indicated that
venom will have his hands full and his
second outing on the big screen in the
scene parties eddie brock an
investigative reporter visits serial
killer Cletus Kasady
played by Woody Harrelson to write a
story about him after a brief and creepy
round of niceties Cassidy makes a
statement that's equal parts threats and
promise when I get out of here and I
will they shouldn't be too hard each
rock maybe a little morally conflicted
but Cassidy created by writer David
Nicolini and artist Erik Larson answered
the unnerving question of what would
happen if a symbiote were to take
control of a truly evil person carnage a
being so unbelievably malevolent and
dangerous that in the comics Spidey and
venom had been forced to team up on
multiple occasions to stop him
Harrelson's returned to take on the
villainous mantle in venom two was
confirmed earlier this year and it's
plain that Hardy is clearly pumped for
fans to witness the epic Throwdown party
caption the image with a coded message
which interestingly could be read as we
are been up to as in the numeral two or
the word - meaning also in the comics
Cassidy symbiote was a spawn of venom so
there could be some interesting subtext
there there's been widespread
speculation that venom 2 will carry an
r-rating but producer Avi Arad told
Collider in 2018 when you hear carnage
the only thing you can think of is our
but if you know his story if you really
know that comic there's no R there he's
a tortured soul it's not about what he
does what you have to show is what is
the motivation was he born like that or
is he someone we should feel for because
if you're succeeding and making a
villain someone you can feel for jackpot
venom - indeed carries the same pg-13
rating as its predecessor this opens the
door to another question especially in
the light of the recent breakup and
reconciliation between Sony Pictures and
Marvel Studios
spider-man let me get together with your
imaginary girlfriend
there has been endless speculation about
whether Hardy's venom and Tom Hollands
spider-man who has appeared in three
Marvel studio films and to Sony produced
MCU set solo vehicles will ever meet on
screen
both actors seem quite psyched about the
prospect and a number of involved
parties have teased that it's not only
possible but inevitable before the Sony
Disney kerfuffle no less an authority
than Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin
Feige said that a crossover quote seems
likely at some point while making it
clear that in his mind that ball was
firmly in Sony's Court after the release
of the mega hit spider-man far from home
director Jon Watts told comic book movie
ComNet creatively speaking he saw no
reason why the comic-book nemec's
couldn't meet up on the big screen at
some point he said I found venom to be
so funny and I thought Tom Hardy was so
great I don't know that the two
universes are so different I think you
put those two Tom's together and you're
going to see something pretty special
while the two stars have in the past
expressed a general interest in working
together
neither have had anything to say about
whether a Spidey venom collision is
officially in the works for Hardy's part
though he couldn't help but throw a bit
of gasoline on that flame with a photo
of himself dressed well rather
provocatively which he posted to and
then deleted from his Instagram account
last month either Hardy knows something
we don't or he simply enjoys screwing
with fans from time to time for the time
being we're gonna have to go with the
latter pollens spider-man has been
confirmed to appear in one more Sony
produced solo flick and an additional
Marvel Studios film at this time and
it's been reported that venom two begins
shooting this month with director Andy
Serkis at the helm whether Spidey makes
an appearance or not though were pumped
to see Hardy's antihero faceoff with one
of the deadliest foes and Marvel Comics
Sony has not yet announced the release
date for venom 2 but the flick is
expected to drop in fall 2020 so we'll
keep our ears to the ground for details
and keep you informed check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about upcoming movie
sequels are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]